the greatest hoax ever perpetrated on
the American tourists public is in rural
Wisconsin and it's wonderful when I was
about 12 years old my parents took me on
a road trip through the Midwest and we
saw a lot of amazing places but there
was one that lodged itself in my
imagination to this day one of the
greatest places I have ever been it's
the house on the rock what makes the
house on the rock so great well let me
throw a few things at you it's got the
world's largest carousel indoors it has
got a sculpture of a squid fighting a
whale that is larger than the Statue of
Liberty there's a room dedicated in
nothing but organs and brewery parts an
enormous collection of antique armor a
collection of antique guns cars hot-air
balloons
an infinite room a collection of self
playing instruments there is an entire
recreation of 1900 s cobblestone street
the entire place is just a mind trippin
brain warp the story goes that when the
Creator
Alex Jordan jr. was a kid and his father
went to see Frank Lloyd Wright and his
father presented Frank Lloyd Wright with
a set of architectural design I'm Frank
Lloyd Wright said I would not hire you
to build a cheese crate or a chicken
coop and the son said I'm gonna grow up
and I'm going to build a house that will
spite Frank Lloyd Wright and that's what
he did he started building on this on
this rock lab rating in this sort of
Frank Lloyd Wright style but with its
own weird twist and then just
accumulating collection after collection
that's the story so there are some
reasons to doubt the authenticity of
this Frank Lloyd Wright story one Frank
Lloyd Wright was in Japan too the
supposed architectural designs submitted
by his father were for a building that
was actually built by a different
architect three the single source for
this story
Sid Boehm who helped build the house on
the rock won the World Championship liar
contest in 1976
making the entire thing a little bit
hard to believe
secondly the houses collections are
completely fake they made the antique
armor they made the antique guns the
mechanical self playing instruments
don't actually play they move and they
and sound is produced but the sound is
not being produced necessarily by the
instruments everything is fake even
though it's not real it is in fact an
incredible expression of Alex Jordans
bizarre mind and artistic pursuit so
while it may be one of the greatest
hoaxes ever perpetrated on the American
tourists public it is also one of the
greatest works of installation art ever
created and that is why I love it click
here to subscribe or click here to watch
our other videos and on Christmas they
fill it with Santa Clauses the they have
like they have like 12,000 santa clauses
and they just put them everywhere and it
makes something that's already insane
even crazier Neil Gaiman wrote about it
in American Gods you ever get a chance
if you really go not don't expect real
stuff just expect the greatest time of
your life what do you think uh the
world's greatest hidden wonders are let
me know in the comments and I can't wait
to hear all about them